bonsoir monsieur bonsoir de poids des
voussoirs je vais pas vous avez une
carte
oui monsieur mais je n'ai pas d'humour
angelina nous avons de toute notion sauf
dans le bourg je viens de vous le dire
le thonier peut-être un peu trop
alcoolisé pour le début de la soirée
mardi
le conseil repart à monsieur si vous on
croyait mon intuition plus carlo je vous
préviens le sujet de cercamp grande
taille tombe bien je sois vous le voulez
exotiques pathétique oasis puis trois et
dix les concours à la boule en 1937 avec
ça va chier
à
c'est à chier
moi j'ai passé des vacances ou quand tu
étais petit écoutez d'ici avant adoptive
antide j'ai mon père était venu de
russie voulait retrouver un peu
l'ambiance de la bible imprimée oui
c'est la merde quoi repose la weed là où
il a été gorbatchev mis en ôta résidence
arrière en deux jours certes au bout de
la crimée et ça correspondait au climat
d'ici ou d'antibes rues de nice cannes
et il a cherché c'est mon père est avec
sa vue le système par région je pleurais
fait et c'est un mec qui est arrivé
déprimé il a su qu'ils partaient meteab
il a mis deux jeunes officiers avaient
19 heures c'est son père et sa mère dit
on le voit plus jamais vous attend parce
que c'est plus possible les rouges vont
arriver et il est il éthique nos chiens
à constantinople six mois est un bateau
qui l'a amené à gas gas sentent musique
est un département série bleue alors est
il en france et il a eut rencontré la
mère en 1942 par jean rostand qui était
un mec formidable avec qui j'ai passé
des là j'ai rencontré un génie jean
rostand
j'ai passé par exemple des heures avec
lui un jour laboratoire où il y avait
2500 beaucoup des tritons avec des
boyaux et on allait chercher ensemble
des communes est retombé dans l'est dans
les étangs est temps que je n'avais pas
compris si vous voulez me dire c'est lui
qui était un conte un génie comme j'en
reste encore 1,6 avis sur tout et ça se
vérifie quand à 8h bull et tu vois avec
comme ça qu'il ya des cheveux blancs qui
prend le temps d'expliquer jusqu'à ce
que tu es compris et c'est là où j'ai
compris que la connerie humaine n'a pas
de limites et qu' il faut de change dix
mois lorsqu'elle est très drôle dans
cette histoire c'est que ton père a
acheté antibes en viager la maison d'un
baron de ville d'avray que ses parents
étaient malades que ton père est devenu
son sens son toubib et s'est occupé de
lui et qu'il l'a tellement bien soigné
c'est que il a vécu les deux sens
jusqu'à vendredi à mon père c'est un
drôle de viager parce qu'il a quand même
duré jusqu'à 100 ans presque oui mon
père un tour et n'ai pas d'argent mais
regagne un peu de pognon mais on fera
jamais gagner de me dit ma mère va
jamais su sur mon père lui a jamais dit
et laissa jamais su
sa mort est gai bi c'était un mec
fabuleux udc russe merde dépenses et où
on sait pas comment un mai et avaient
envie de retrouver ça
son pays et quand il est arrivé à
antibes il a trouvé cette maison en
viager de barons de ville d'avray que le
rendu de la rue avait 77 ans ça fait
presque 15 ans et la politesse de vos
reer besoin après que nous raconte les
histoires fabuleux résister magnifique
cité chanson gabor de raconter les
histoires l'accent hongrois et lui ne
voulais que mon père médecin veut il
avait 77 ans et on a vécu pendant 20 ans
dans la cave de notre maison est
soi-disant acheter alors je barre on
avait tout le reste
quel merveilleux baron d'ailleurs je lui
en veux pas parce que mon père et de son
médecin qui l'avait vu j'ai 90 1 c'était
humide c'était son vous avez passé 22
ans la cua ou non c'était juste un peu
mieux son nom faisait merveilleux
l'endroit a des souvenirs de vacances de
l'époque c'est la pêche avec ton père tu
partais à 5 heures du matin aux trois
heures et puis c'est quand l'ibère cap
d'antibes à l'époque c'est à dire
c'était pas comme maintenant il y avait
si je pouvais te raconter tout ce qui se
passe est ajournée par et vaincu réduit
à l'époque dorée sur l'église et qui
laissait 5 200 mecs dormir à l'église et
que ces écoutes ont décerné today à
germain des prés et brutalement il y
avait claude lutter sidney bechet
après les festivals de jazz s'est passé
c'était magnifique et sur la plage
la tâche des pirates à jour l'état on
finissait avec la contrebasse j'ai vu un
jour dizzy gillespie jouer assis dans
une boue et de la trompette donc son
bassiste désormais menton un temps
d'expliquer de la bcge est connue
n'existe page des magnifiques et jeudi
c'était avant ça te restait avant que
bardot oui j'en ai pas été dans la
station l'avocat jack bauer
c'était cette époque un jour ton père
part à la pêche tt shop a tenu une
dizaine d'années par la pêche tout de
suit en vélo sur les remparts et tu
tombes
comment tu sais ça je sais tout ça mais
c'est une histoire extraordinaire parce
que tu tombes et très jeune j'étais
tellement amoureux de mon père
ce qu'on fait c'est mon père qui m'a
ma vie c'est pas ma mère du monde croit
on demande toujours quel seuil de 3
halls tôt ma mère a toujours dit que ces
enfants n'étaient pas si 15 humains
puisque mon père dirigeait ma vie et je
l'aimé je sais que j'aime et boris et il
mérite y acheter des appareils devaient
être 5 heures du matin - 6 heures je
fonce au port je m'étais pas réveillée
et puis revenant je notais slayers un
jeu les remparts d'antibes et je tombe
de 6,7 mètres de haut et j'ai vu une
chose c'est pas si tu l'as vu déjà toi
c'est ce qu'on raconte des choses de la
vie
le film d'auteur vrai c'est ça qui est
étonnant que c'était la buteuse en
jamais non jamais ai-je déjà que je
m'est arrivé je suis tombé la tête en
avant des remparts d'antibes en vélo
comme à nous et j'ai vu jour ce
magnifique dire que tu vois les plus
beaux moments de sa vie sains comme un
film en couleur tu vas mourir j'ai
réussi à savoir pourquoi je disais
sportif à l'époque à retomber sont des
gens me suis classé avec deux jambes
mais j'ai vu ma vie en couleurs
et j'avais voulu mourir et je suis tombé
dans les bras d'un pote à moi qui étais
pompiers auxiliaires de 17 ans qui m'a
amené j'ai vu ce pote à mourir devant
moi un an après on mangeait avec
beaucoup de choses qui sont pris
quelques elle sait qu'elle tu as gardé
de cette 2ème jour là est devenu gros tu
vois aussi je suis aucune idée je ne
sais pas si c'est gore du ler
psychosomatiques ou pain je fais du yoga
j'étais j'aurais disant ouais mais bon
ça m'a aidé dans la vie parce qu'après
il était haltérophiles j'étais du dock
invite les internautes à 14 ans mais
j'avais 10 ans et j'ai grossi un batteur
un gros site
disons que je suis devenu gré se pare
brise était vraiment un petit mec je
suis dangereux
jean carlos est vrai que quand tu étais
petit antide tu mettais un masque et
puis tu te mettais la hauteur de l'eau
comme ça avec la moitié au dessus et la
moitié ou dessous et puis tu te demander
dans quelle dans quel univers si vous
voulez vivre si tu voulais vivre au
dessus de l'eau en dessous de l'oreille
je veux mon masque de biche ou mariné au
masque un petit jardin et je voyais un
petit peu de la vie et robbie c'est à
dire des gens qui vivaient sur la met
sur les routes ce n'est pas tout les
immeubles qu'ils aient et je voyais
aussi le même sous marins je me suis dit
c'est la sélective c'est un roman je me
livre épique j'ai découvert ce site que
l'eau c'était vraiment un élément jus
poisson vrai et d'ailleurs toi avec le
poids que tu fais faut bien dire que
dans l'eau c'est mieux pour toi moi
aussi me nadji madou tranquille tu fais
un rêve serait elle expliqué le tout
dans le monde des quêtes battre l'autre
je me donne un couac quelle que soit la
mer en général et la mer
personne ne le sait ça
c'est le liquide amniotique c'est
exactement le même on est dans le ventre
de la vente d'un moment c'est un côté
dolto ça la mère et la mère sur l'avenir
et me et re jamais rêvé aussi quand on
sait pas comment ça fonctionne mais je
te jure que toi tu es dans l'eau quand
il se dit comme c'est bien je te
retrouve dans le ventre de tout moment
mais dis moi ce que tu as peur c'est
beau hein tu t'appelles yvan chrisostome
sait ce que ça veut dire chrisostome oui
chrysostomos soyaux bouche d'or bouche
d'or car pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou